Good afternoon, everyone
and welcome to this week's CIFAR webinar,
Science is the Exit Strategy.
This is a series of virtual
talks that we're hosting
to showcase how research
from across disciplines
from computer science to
population and public health,
economics and anthropology can help
to inform our public health
and economic response
in the wake of COVID-19.
If you don't know us,
CIFAR is a Canadian based
global research organization
and our mission and mandate really are
to bring the world's
top researchers together
from around the world
and across disciplines
to address important
questions facing society.
Like many others across the
globe CIFAR has pivoted quickly
to take action on COVID-19.
We've launched many new
projects, new initiatives
and we're highlighting
those through this series.
My name is Elissa Strome,
I'm the executive director of
the Pan-Canadian AI strategy
and the associate vice
president research at CIFAR.
It's my distinct pleasure
today to introduce you
to professor Kim McGrail.
She is a professor at UBC
in the School of Population
and Public Health and the
Center for Health Services
and Policy Research.
She is director of
research with UBC Health.
She is scientific director
of Population Health Data BC
and I think most relevant
to our conversation today,
she is scientific director
of Health Data Research Network Canada.
Welcome Kim, thank you for joining us.
Before we begin today's session,
I wanna take care of a
few housekeeping issues.
There goes a truck outside the window.
Today's session will last
approximately 30 minutes,
Kim and I will have a conversation
and then we'll gladly open
it up to your questions.
Please send those questions
in through the Q&A function
and we'll do our best to answer
as many of them as possible
at the end of our conversation.
This session is being
recorded and will be available
on the CIFAR website next week.
So let's jump right in.
Kim, thanks again for joining us today.
It's great to have this
opportunity to talk
to you about the work that you
and your colleagues are doing
at Health Data Research Network Canada
to coordinate and integrate
data across the country
to advance health research.
Let's start the conversation
by having you describe a
little bit about HDRN Canada,
including its vision and
its partnership model.
- Great, thanks for the opportunity.
It's great to have this
conversation with you today.
So Health Data Research Network Canada
is a newly incorporated, not for profit
and it's a Pan-Canadian network
that is meant to facilitate
and accelerate
multi-jurisdictional research.
So our network includes data centers
and other organizations
representing all provinces
and Northwest territory
and we're working on bringing
in Nunavut and Yukon as well
plus Statistics Canada
and the Canadian Institute for
Health Information or CIHI.
There's a starting position of our network
and the reason we started working together
over five years ago,
well before we had any funding
to actually do the kind
of work we're doing now is
that we really looked across the country
and see that we have this
position in the world
of data where the glass
really is 3/4 full.
We've got lots of strength
at the national level
and in our individual
provinces and territories
but a lot of difficulty in
actually doing a good deal
of multi-jurisdictional research
and we really felt that
if we had just the ability
to add a little bit more,
we could leverage all
of those great existing resources
and really promote a lot of
more innovative research.
So we're a distributed network
and we have a commitment
to distributing funding.
We're not creating something central.
We're not trying to
create a single database
across the country
and part of that is
because we have a principle
of respecting local
context and local policies
and taking comers as they
come without demanding
that they act a certain
way or be a certain thing
in order to be part of our network
and we're leveraging wherever possible.
So we're not trying to build something new
if something excellent already
exists in the world of data,
data resources and access and so on.
So just very briefly, we
have seven objectives overall
for our network.
One is to create a data
access support system
to help navigate
multi-jurisdictional researchers,
so it's one stop shopping,
one form, one request process.
We're working to harmonize
and validate definitions
for important chronic
diseases and other variables
so we can have apples
to apples comparisons
of data across the country.
We're continuing to
expand the types of data
that are available.
Our bedrock really is administrative data
and population-based information
but we can link that
to cohorts, to surveys,
to electronic medical records
and other things as they become available.
We're developing technology infrastructure
to improve the request process
but also documentation storage, metadata
and other things really
and this is an eye towards sustainability
of the network and the functions.
We're creating supports
for advanced analytics
and infrastructure for data analysis
and really focusing there
on distributed data analysis
because we know this is one
of the ways of the future.
We're establishing really
strong partnerships
with patients, the public
and indigenous communities
and this is really around
underlining the ethics
of data use,
particularly as data
resources are changing so much
and building strong governance
to enable national coordination,
ways of working together,
we have the strength from everybody.
So you can see that our work
really is around organizing
and making data available.
The technical supports around
that and really a strong focus
on ethics and engagement
and then of course,
transparency and sustainability.
- It's an amazing initiative
and it's so incredibly
foundational to our ability
to really analyze and assess
and understand the impact
on health of Canadians across
the country and the work
that you're doing is
clearly a huge step forward
from where we have been in the past.
So just so that we understand
it a little bit more deeply.
So through HDRN,
researchers can access data
from across provinces and territories,
from across different health systems
and even across different data holders
like Statistics Canada.
As I said, it's a huge step forward
and so tell us a little bit about
what are the key
advantages for researchers
to having this kind of broad,
multi-jurisdictional access.
Why have we not been able
to do that in the past
and what are the remaining
challenges that you're tackling?
- Great question.
So I'll start with why
this has been so difficult
and really wanna start
there by acknowledging
that not everything is difficult,
some things have really
been done quite well.
So CIHI has a number of
Pan-Canadian datasets
that are available and have
been available to researchers
for quite some time
and Statistics Canada clearly has amazing
and rich data resources
and a research data center network
that has helped researchers
get access to those
and of course, a number
of provinces have good,
really good data and support
for access to those as well
but having said that
it has been absolutely
a really big challenge
and really a loss to all of
us that we haven't been able
to conduct all of the
multi-jurisdictional research
that researchers are trying
to propose and put forward
and Pan-Canadian projects
that extend really just
beyond the data of a single organization,
that's where we really
struggle is working together
across organizations.
I think there's two kind of
fundamental reasons for this.
One is the nature of
our Canadian Federation
and the tension that that kind of sets up
between provinces and territories
and the federal government
and that's a whole political
science conversation
but I do think it's
important to acknowledge
that that is part of what's going on here.
The other is that because provinces
and territories have their
individual responsibility
for delivery of healthcare
and other kinds of services,
the data they collect, the
way that they're collected
and the technical systems that
they use to collect the data,
even the services that
are covered are different
and this really creates a challenge for,
again, the apples to apples comparison
but also the ability just to assemble
and then use the data appropriately.
So having said all of that,
the advantages that come
from addressing this
are that we can look at the effect.
It's a natural laboratory in Canada,
we have different policies
and different practices,
so we can learn from those
if we can compare across jurisdictions.
We can also at a national
level look at the effects
of small populations,
small number of conditions
or people who have had a
relatively unique service
and really at the Pan-Canadian level
for those small populations
that's the only way we can
do some of this research.
So we do still have lots of challenges,
including sharing of
data across boundaries
and at this point I'd also say
that we really haven't had
enough engagement with the public
around the ethical
issues of doing the kind
of data linkage and analysis
that we really wanna do.
- Great and I know that
you're working hard
on that front and you
mentioned earlier the work
that you do in engaging with
indigenous communities as well.
One of the things that just occurred
to me as you were speaking, Kim,
I wonder if one of the other
advantages of integrating
and coordinating access to
data across the country,
health data in particular
across the country
is really being able
to take full advantage
of the diversity of the
population in Canada,
which is distributed across the country.
Do you see that as another advantage?
- Oh, yes and this is
probably highlighted really
with the COVID pandemic
and a lot of the discussion
that's been happening around
vulnerable populations
and communities, race-based
data and that sort of thing.
If you really want to be able
to truly understand small
populations, rural populations,
certain kind of racial and
ethnic minority populations,
it's probably much better
to have a larger group,
a larger population being
the Canadian population
to start from in those cases.
- Great and I know from the very beginning
of the pandemic HDRN pivoted very quickly
to say what can we do
specifically to understand
and address COVID-19,
what can we do to understand
how it's affecting Canadians,
how it's affecting health systems
and the demand on health systems.
Can you give us a couple of
examples of what HDRN did
to address COVID and is
doing to address COVID
and also maybe some of
the specific projects
that researchers are leveraging
the HDRN data network
in order to address?
- Yeah, we did recognize
early on that there was a role
for us, even in a starting
point of sharing information,
making researchers aware and in one spot,
similar to what we've done in other cases
of what data might be available,
in which provinces that
could support COVID research
and on the first instance
that meant documenting where
COVID testing data were going
to be available for research access
and what other kinds of data sets
that those could be linked to
and so we put together,
it was weekly at first
and we've gone to a little bit
more, less frequent updating
of a briefing note just
to describe where we are,
the new features that are available
and just more recently,
I think it's just today
that came out, we have
been working on metadata
for the COVID data and in
the coming months I expect
that we'll be increasing
focus on the other data sets
that we might be able to link as we start
to think about research
on the broader effects
of COVID, beyond the
people who've had the virus
to thinking about the broader effects
on communities and individuals
and at this point, of
course, there's no projects
that have gone through the whole process
and been completed
through the HDRN supports
but we've been working
with a lot of researchers
on pursuing potential topics
or studies they might wanna do
and working with some specific ones
on funded projects now ranging
from emergency department use
and in that case, we're
working with a team
that's actually assembling a new data set
that will be available to others as well
to virtual care, reproductive
care and pregnancy outcomes.
So there's wide range of things.
- So the full spectrum of what we can do
with the data that we have.
I know as a sort of an
interested stakeholder
in the ecosystem,
I've really appreciated getting
your COVID-19 briefing notes
on a regular basis to
just maintain my awareness
about what's going on and what's available
for researchers so that I can share
it amongst my community as well.
So I think we're just about
ready to head into questions.
So I just wanna let the
audience know that we'll head
to questions after our
next topic of discussion.
So if you've got
questions, please put them
into the Q&A box for us and
we'll get to them right away
but the last topic that
I wanna touch on sort
of formally with Kim is the fact
that over the last year, she
and I have worked together
and had the opportunity to
work with 15 other leaders
from across the AI and health
research innovation ecosystems
in a national AI for health task force
and what we've been doing
is developing a series
of recommendations to both
the federal government
and provincial and territorial governments
towards a national AI for health strategy.
The report of the AI for health
taskforce which we've titled
Building a Learning Health
System For Canadians
is now available on the CIFAR website.
So Kim, let's hear from you a
little bit about why you think
it's so important that we
have a national strategy on AI
for health and how it will
deliver benefits to Canadians.
- I really appreciate being
able to talk about this
because it was such a pleasure to work
as part of that task force
and you produced a fantastic report.
So congratulations on that.
So I think it's important to start just
from the basics of AI
and just my perspective
on this is AI has like many technologies,
probably like any technology at all,
it has a great potential for good
but equally can be used to produce harm
and it could be unintended
consequences, it's still harm.
In addition, AI is one of the drivers,
is what has been described
as the fourth industrial revolution
and should we kind of summarize
what I think people are
talking about when they see
it's this kind of continuation
of the digital revolution
that's kind of starting
to blur the distinctions between
or to kind of combine physical, biological
and computing kind of processes.
So man and machine kind
of a framework of things.
So in other words, it's expected
that AI is gonna be really
disruptive to business,
to governance and to our daily lives
and if we believe this then
I think it's really important
that we have a coordinated strategy.
First of all, to make sure
that we truly understand what's happening
and both the unintended
and intended consequences
and that we have a handle
on how best to make sure
that we get good things out of AI
and secondly, that we mitigate
any negative consequences
if we are able to do so.
So then if we think more
specifically about health
and the health care system in Canada
it makes sense for us to
focus on health in part,
I mean, we have a ongoing
abiding, respect and love
for a universal healthcare system with all
its imperfections, it is
still a great building block
and hopefully we can continue
to make improvements in that.
The AI approaches in health
can accommodate a large amount
of data, including images,
they can help us make sense
of this vast quantity of information,
it can improve efficiency and diagnostics
and AI systems can be used
to augment human activities,
so they can help make providers
provide better services
but they also could do
things like help people live
in their homes for longer
and augment those informal
supports as people age.
So ultimately I think we
need a Pan-Canadian strategy
in AI for health because it
is a disruptive potential
of this technology, because of the changes
in the infrastructure that are needed
for AI are significant
and because AI in health is
ultimately a global issue
and if we want to have
some influence on that
at a global level, we need to
work in a Pan-Canadian way.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I think on that last
point, one of the things
that we discussed a lot at the task force,
of course, we talked a lot about data
and data access, you'd recall
and other members of
the task force I see are
on this webinar in the audience today,
we spent an inordinate amount
of time talking about data and data access
and the pandemic has
really actually allowed us
as a research and innovation community
to make some important steps
and HDRN has really been
leading the way on that
but the other thing that we spent a lot
of time talking about
at the task force was
really Canada's opportunity
around the application of AI to health
and our specific opportunity
because we are a great leading AI nation,
we have tremendous expertise
in this field across the country,
because we have such
strong values around AI
and its use in a responsible
and ethical manner
and especially when we're
talking about health
and when we're talking
about personal data,
those principles and values
are so incredibly crucial
but also the opportunity
to really leverage
that publicly funded
health system that we have
and the fact that the
data is and should be
and can be made available
for research and innovation.
So it was such a wide ranging conversation
and we probably could have
had 100 recommendations
in our report and we worked so hard
to really narrow them down
to the focus of the things
that we felt as a committee
were essential first steps
in moving Canada forward
to really take advantage
of all of this and bottom line being,
better health for Canadians
and I think that's the
vision of the task force.
So thanks to you for all of
your contributions to that work
and as I said, we've
got a couple of members
of the task force I can see are
on our participant list today,
so thanks to everybody for their efforts.
So let's move to the
audience questions now
and we'll start with a quick
one actually from Randy Goebel,
a colleague of ours on the task force
from the university of Alberta
and from Amii our AI
Institute in Edmonton,
really quick question,
Randy asks, "Is there an EARL
"that provides information
about our research access
"to health systems COVID test data."
Randy, I think what you're asking for is
how do you find out what data is available
about COVID testing through HDRN
and the answer to that is you
can go to the HDRN website
and it's all on there and
look for their briefs as well
and the brief today actually speaks
to the metadata that's available.
So another question that's come in.
The participant asks,
"What are the most expected
worries regarding data sharing
"from the population and data owners?"
So really the concern that
citizens have and the concerns
that the public have about data sharing.
Can you outline some of that
for us Kim, please?
- Sure.
It's a difficult question
to answer in part
because I don't wanna pretend
to speak on behalf of all Canadians.
What I can speak to is
the existing literature
that has resulted from a pretty
deep public deliberation,
including focus groups but
longer deliberations sessions
as well and I have been
leading some of those
in British Columbia but
there's an international group
of people who've been working in this area
and interestingly, there's quite a lot
of consistency across countries
from what we can see in this.
So people are really, really
open to having their data used
for research but it's always
in context with provisos
and those provisos really revolve
around the Five Safes framework
and this is a framework
that's been emerging as just,
it doesn't say what needs to be done
but it tells you what
you need to think about
and what those things are is safe people.
So who is it that's accessing the data
and people have a lot of
trust for researchers,
university-based researchers.
They start to get a little more concerned
if we're talking about private industry
and it's not, I don't wanna
say that it's a hard no,
it's just that it changes
the conversation a bit
and there's different considerations.
So safe people is a big one.
Safe environments.
Where are you gonna be doing the research?
And increasingly people
expect things to be done
in a controlled, secure
environment because that just says
that you've got greater
control over what's happening.
Safe projects.
So what is the question that's being asked
and who's vetted it to say
that it has scientific merit
and will produce some public value?
Safe data.
So this is how identifying are the data
that are going to be used
and have things been done
to at least remove direct identifiers,
names and addresses and things like that?
And safe outputs, what's coming out?
What's gonna be shared publicly?
Is there potential for
harm to come to individuals
or communities, small
populations based on that?
So those are the things that
the public worries about,
less blanket or strict yes or no
and more what's being done to protect data
and put some guardrails around use.
- Great and that Five
Safes framework I found
in researching this field
and working on the task force
was really such an
excellent conceptual model
to think about what are the things
that we have to be concerned about?
What are the questions that we need
to be asking ourselves as researchers,
as we're considering the
use of individual data?
So along the same lines, we
have a question that came in
from another one of our
participants about the type of work
that you're doing around community public
and patient engagement.
So he asks you to speak more
to community patient engagement
in the HDRN and how that
interfaces with the idea
that individual participant
consent is not required
in studies of administrative data.
"Thank you", he says.
- Yeah, great question
because of course, again, the bedrock,
not all of the data that
we have is this kind
of what we call unconsented
data but a big portion of it is
and they're unconsented in the
sense that there's allowances
for use of these data in
the absence of consent,
again, with the guardrails around that.
So when we are talking about
public and patient engagement
in Health Data Research Network Canada,
we're really focusing on data specifically
and I contrast that with
the broader strategy
for patient-oriented research from CIHR,
which is what we're funded under.
So this really is a focus on
how are we gonna use data?
What kind of data should we be bringing in
and what are the limits to allowances
for research uses of that information?
So we have established an
interim public advisory council
for HDRN, we're just in
the process of recruiting
and filling out a permanent
structure for that
and we will be looking to
that group for helping us
with a number of things.
One is communication.
So we really feel that
transparency is kind
of the first order of
business for the activities
that HDRN is doing
but another is really to
help truly create a space
where the public has an influence
on the policies around data use
and then I think we will
absolutely take direction
from that advisory
committee on other things
that we should be considering,
whether that's about information flows
or about doing things differently
and I do wanna emphasize
that I personally feel
very committed to the fact
that the public needs to have a true say
and this is not just a PR
communications exercise.
- Absolutely and it can't
be tokenism in any way.
It has to be really deep engagements,
consideration, collaboration
with the public
and with patients and we
articulated that very strongly
in the taskforce report,
very much taking inspiration from the work
that you've done at HDRN and
that others have done across
the country on this topic,
really thinking about the role
of citizens in understanding
and contributing to
this work going forward.
I was always inspired by
the UK where they seem
to have a very strong
culture of data trust
and I think that's something
that we can learn a lot from
and aspire to build in Canada,
this culture of inclusion
within the governance,
within decision making around data
and that's how you engender trust
and how you're able to
advance research objectives.
Another couple of quick
questions about HDRN,
another colleague asks,
"Are there any plans to reach
out beyond our boundaries
to coordinate with other countries?"
Yes as a matter of fact, we
have a partnership around COVID
with the UK Health Data Research group
and we're working on a
memorandum of understanding
for larger work with them.
In fact, we're working
with them on metadata now,
because with the idea being
that metadata being how we
describe the data that we have,
if we can align metadata
then we are effectively
aligning the potential
for international
collaborative research project.
So we're working with them so
that we can get those things in place now.
- I think it's such a great partner for us
because they have so many similarities
in their health system, in
their principles, values,
democracy and have been a
real leader in this space,
so I think that UK is always
a great example to look to.
- Yep.
- Last question about HDRN
and then we'll start to wrap up.
For provinces who are looking
to build their own internal
capacity for data collection
and sharing can or does
the HDRN assist them
in accelerating those improvements?
- Oh, it's such a great question.
Yeah, it's one of the things
that we have found over
the last couple of years
of really working together more formally,
it's one of the greatest
assets we can provide
is all the learning and information
from the existing centers to
share with those who are trying
to start up but honestly, equally it goes
in the other direction as well.
So we have established, for
example a privacy working group
of all the privacy leads
from our organizations
across the country and they're helping
to do a number of things
on legislative review
and that sort of thing.
So absolutely those resources are there
and we're really open
to helping as we can.
- Awesome, so this has been
a fabulous conversation.
Thank you, Kim for joining me today,
it's gone by very quickly
as these always do
and I'm afraid we don't have
time for any further questions.
I wanna remind the audience
that the AI for health taskforce
report is now available
on the CIFAR website and
before you sign off I'd like
to thank everybody for joining us today
for this conversation and I'd
especially like thank you, Kim
for telling us the story of HDRN Canada
and the amazing foundation
that it has laid to integrate
and coordinate data across the country
and make it available for research.
CIFAR's virtual talk series
continues on August 20th
with CIFAR president Dr. Alan
Bernstein in conversation
with professor Arturo Casadevall
from the Johns Hopkins School of Medicine
and he's doing groundbreaking
work on the use of plasma
for the prevention and
therapy of COVID-19,
I hope that you can join us then.
Please visit our website cifar.ca
to find out more about the series
and to view our recording
from today's talk,
which will be posted early next week.
Thanks again to everybody for joining us
and have a wonderful afternoon, bye bye.